we begin with this after months of talk
about Russian election meddling there is
now clear evidence that Russia's
government wanted to help elect Donald
Trump emails show that Donald Trump jr.
was told in June of last year that the
Russians wanted to provide information
to hurt Hillary Clinton's campaign
publicist Rob Goldstone told Trump jr.
this is obviously very high-level and
sensitive information but is part of
Russia and it's government's support for
mr. Trump Trump jr. responded if it's
what you say I love it
presidents oldest son released a string
of emails of the New York Times was
about to publish and he talked at length
last night about meeting with a Russian
lawyer that he said produced nothing
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
where the president is defending his son
Margaret good morning good morning this
is a major distraction for the Trump
White House this morning President Trump
is defending his son calling him open
transparent and honest and despite all
these new revelations he's continuing to
call the Russia's story a political
witch-hunt in retrospect I probably
would have done things a little
differently again this is before the
Russia mania this is before they were
building it up in the press for me this
was opposition research on Fox News
Donald Trump jr. admitted his meeting
with Russian lawyer Natalia vessel nets
kaya was a mistake and he said she did
not deliver on the promise of sharing
damaging information on Hillary Clinton
but really it went nowhere and it was
apparent that that wasn't what the
meeting was actually about the emails
released by Trump jr. on Tuesday were
explicit a friend Rob Goldstone wrote to
the president's son last June offering
quote information that would incriminate
Hillary and would be very useful to your
father he called it part of Russia and
it's government's support for mr. Trump
Trump jr. responded saying if it's what
you say I love it the information
Goldstone wrote was from Russian
government sources and was shared with
russian pop star and min Guevara and his
father a wealthy oligarch with ties to
Vladimir Putin the same individuals who
helped mr. Trump bring the Miss Universe
pageant to Moscow in 2013 someone sent
me an email
I can't help what someone sends me Trump
jr. claims he never mentioned it to his
father it was such a nothing
there was nothing to tell I mean I
wouldn't even remembered it until you
start scouring through the stuff
Trump juniors attorney Alan Feder Foss
was a sought out defense lawyer for
accused mobsters told CBS News that
Trump jr. was simply doing someone a
favor by meeting with vets on its Kyah
on Tuesday bets on the skaia disputed
any friend linked eyes telling The
Associated Press I do not represent
interests of anyone other than myself a
month after the meeting Donald Trump jr.
attacked Democrats for suggesting
Russians were trying to help the Trump
campaign well it just goes to show you
their exact moral compass I mean they'll
say anything to be able to win this I
mean this is time and time again lie
after lie it's disgusting it's so phony
attorney Shannon coffin former general
counsel in the Bush administration said
Donald Jr committed political
malpractice but so far nothing illegal
sure it seems like Donald Trump jr. was
willing to accept whatever help he could
get to get his father elected but but
there's no evidence that he was doing so
through an illegal means Trump jr. also
copied campaign Sheriff Paul Manafort
as well as his brother-in-law Jared
Kushner on the email both of them also
attended the meeting and Gayle that is
raising new questions about Kushner
security clearance here at the White
House all right another story we're
following thank you very much Margaret